jacuzzi l'arrêt tu peux tirer à 1h je
suis comme en diesel action salut
bruisser ayari je vais y revenir
[Musique]
et
voilà c'est bien
bah non c'est la gamme
ces dernières
jeanne d'arc c'est un morceau que
j'avais fait déjà de base pour moi et
que j'avais pas sortir en vrai et s'est
avéré que j'avais besoin d'un trou pour
annoncer la sortie d'album et j'ai fait
aux soldats j'ai même pas fini leçons
quand j'avais dix soldats j'ai fait un
petit morceau de soldats et je débats
lancés sur les réseaux sociaux pour un
entraîneur un droit et là quand j'ai
sorti ça et je vois et des commentaires
en mode oui on attend que l'album sorte
ura soldats et patati et patata
et quand nakamura est sorti va élever
passe à son tour l'a vu et ça commence à
dire ennuis commencent à y a pas un
soldat est au moins le sixième il est de
base n'était pas prévu dans la loi tu
vois ce que je veux dire
et quand
au fur et à mesure du temps tu te rends
compte que les gens ils lâchent pas
battu di bacco flipper alors j'ai joué
du fond nous sommes là mais voilà et
d'après ce que j'ai compris je vais
apparaître au long du clip et
disparaître
je ne suis pas là comme un spectre a
monté d un peu s'il en faut on n'a pas
pas
les classes on a tout bas
c'est pas fait la lumière comme ça on a
les filles que la déco etc
derrière tous genres voilà quoi c'est
voir l'arrivée de l'amendement va ce
bail et on se connaît bien
c'est cool c'est ça se passe bien c'est
fluide on s'entend bien moment les clips
sont pas trop mal donc on va essayer de
continuer maintenant c'est cool ça fait
plaisir
savage connaître des bus et il faut se
motiver mais je suis je suis comme un
diesel comme eux non mais franchement ça
va on vient de commencer
c'est le début de tournage après
margaret et
c'est chaud jusqu'au bout
on a encore en plein milieu de la
journée s'est dit très content de la
première c'est la rue je voulais et ça
rend bien compte en ce moment et
on va dire un peu notre artiste avec qui
on travaille beaucoup
ici c'est la mif sur le poteau on se
tape des barres mon travail et voilà bah
comme laon l'accompagnant tournage on
est là sur les clips on était là pour
qui elle était là avec nous pour je m'en
tape
donc voilà ça se passe super bien
il est cependant son qui fait danser les
faire avancer
c'est ça et il a un gros potentiel et
même l ajustement un extrait de 30
secondes il ya quatre parole mais les
gens déjà ils connaissent tous ils
attendent la chute et ça ça fait plaisir
de faire le triplé de pouvoir le sortir
en fin de mois
tu pourras était pourtant à toi de tête
aux pieds c'est que le temps va secouer
toi que je dépasse et là tu mettras
ceinture
[Musique]
et j'ai vingt-huit choqué bon
franchement je suis un pirate choquer
mais je compte en temps franchement ce
cas pareils ans déjà qu'il ya trois
semaines personnes qui ont écouté mon
album
laurent ournac se marrer en iconique moi
c'est mon vivant
enfin jack aussi forte
sortez les maillots moi je dis tu veux
quoi à cjb suis bien
vas-y
tu as vu l'a vu comment les magnifiques
c'est trop
[Musique]
bon c'est bon pour aujourd'hui ça
dommage bonjour net genre de journée
pardon par deux choses que ça va
tranquille ça va le faire j'espère j'ai
même pas ce qu'il va demain en faire il
ya le canapé c'est les plans avec giro
j' attends attends à la fiesta là
[Musique]
je porte ce dos au 300 mines vente et à
toute l'équipe présente pour le tournage
de soldats et merci encore d'être là
merci à brut et merci aux personnes qui
ont acheté l